nach den krawallen von stuttgart der
bundesinnenminister spricht von einem
alarmsignal für den rechtsstaat und
fordert harte strafen immer mehr corona
fälle in gütersloh arbeitsminister heil
will den fleischkonzern tönnies für die
schäden zahlen lassen
mallorca im stresstest tausende deutsche
erleben den urlaub auf der baleareninsel
mit corona schutzmaßnahmen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten um 7 norbert
lehmann hat den sport dazu mitgebracht
einen schönen dorf vor mir
das hat stuttgart so noch nicht erlebt
den ausbruch exzessiver gewalt durch
junge männer verschiedenster herkunft
nach einer polizeikontrolle eine gewalt
die sich vor allem gegen die polizei
entlud aber auch gegen unbeteiligte
passanten
jetzt werden parteiübergreifend harte
konsequenzen gefordert
später samstagabend in der stuttgarter
innenstadt die klubs sind corona bedingt
geschlossen gefeiert wird draußen nach
einer drogenkontrolle eskaliert die
situation hunderte randalierende werfen
mit flaschen und steinen greifen die
polizisten an
am ende sind 19 beamte verletzt etliche
geschäfte beschädigt und geplündert aus
stuttgart eva schiller
sie wollen härte demonstrieren der
polizei den rücken stärken und zwar
nicht irgendwo und so besucht
innenminister seehofer flankiert von
ministerpräsident und bürgermeister den
stuttgarter schlossplatz dort wo sich
die gewalt entladen hat und das
entsetzen greifbar ist
ich hoffe jetzt dass die täter
vollständig ermittelt werden dass sie
einer raschen und harten verurteilung
durch die justiz zugeführt werden
währenddessen fegen durch corona ohnehin
leidgeprüfte ladenbesitzer scherben
der schaden geht in die millionenhöhe es
hat uns gerade noch gefehlt
was ihn so schwer schweren zeiten in
denen wir uns befinden
ein junger männer die hauskreisen an
nach seine gewaltorgie in gang setzen
die polizei versucht derweil
hintergründe der gewalttat aufzuklären
sofern es welche gibt nach einer
drogenkontrolle ziehen am samstag junge
männer mit und ohne
migrationshintergrund randalieren durch
stuttgart die inszenierung der brutalen
daten im netz und ihr hass gegen die
polizei scheint der größte gemeinsame
nenner
nach stunden werden 25 junge männer
festgenommen die hälfte von ihnen
deutsche ihnen vereint ist diese
stimmung die gegen die polizei in den
letzten wochen und monaten zu beobachten
war in deutschland und wir haben einfach
wie gesagt die gunst der stunde genutzt
um wie viel gewalt ausleben zu können
es gibt keine entschuldigung für das was
passiert ist sagen streetworker aber sie
beobachten seit wochen wie mit dem
corona frust bei jugendlichen die
gewaltbereitschaft wächst das ist nicht
unbedingt eine sache von
migrationshintergrund ja oder nein das
ist eher eine sache von habe ich eine
perspektive weiß ich was mit meinem
leben anzufangen wo will ich hin sieben
beschuldigte wurden heute dem
haftrichter vorgeführt gegen einen 16
jährigen wurde haftbefehl wegen
versuchten totschlags erlassen weil er
einen studenten gegen den kopf getreten
haben soll
als der die ausschreitungen kritisierte
da bleiben fragen offen an unsere
korrespondentinnen in berlin und
stuttgart zuerst eva schiller
warum gerade stuttgart gab es denn
irgendwelche anzeichen für diese
eskalation dort ja ich habe heute mit
polizisten gesprochen mit psychologen
und sozialarbeitern und so richtig
konnte mir keiner die frage beantworten
warum stuttgart es ist wohl wirklich ein
unheilvoller mix der da zu diesem
exklusiven gewaltausbruch der dann zu
diesem gewaltausbruch geführt hat wir
waren auf der einen seite frustrierte
junge männer die seit wochen durch die
korona maßnahmen immer wieder des
platzes verwiesen wurden von der polizei
ermahnt wurden und im netz hat sich der
hass auf die polizei wohl in den letzten
wochen schon sehr stark hochgeschaukelt
und es dann letztendlich auf die straße
geschwappt also es hätte wahrscheinlich
in jeder deutschen großstadt passieren
können mit dem unterschied vielleicht
dass die stuttgarter polizei weniger auf
so einen gewaltausbruch vorbereitet war
wie vielleicht polizei in hamburg oder
berlin energy in berlin
wie kommt es dass ein doch letztlich
lokales ereignis so viel besorgnis in
der hauptstadt auslöst
ja weil man hier davon ausgeht dass es
eben nicht nur lokal und nicht nur
corona bedingter frust ist er sich dort
waren gebrochen hat in einem wirklich
seltenen schulterschluss sagen hier
heute alle im bundestag vertretenen
parteien das ist ausdruck einer
gesamtgesellschaftlichen entwicklung
einer steigenden gewaltbereitschaft
gegenüber polizisten aber auch gegenüber
feuerwehr und sanitäter
das haben wir in den letzten monaten
erlebt da gab es auch angriffe zum teil
gezielte angriffe und hinterhalte und
das sorgt hier wirklich für große
besorgnis man ist sich einig da ist der
rechtsstaat bedroht wenn sich das nicht
einfangen lässt wenn sich das weiter
entwickelt und das sollte nicht
passieren hier ist auch die rede von
verhältnissen wie in frankreich wo wir
in den letzten jahren immer wieder
gewaltsame auseinandersetzungen zwischen
jungen menschen und der polizei gesehen
haben das möchte man hier verhindern
aber da ist die einigkeit dann auch
schon zu ende denn bei der frage wie man
das verhindert da gibt es sehr viele
unterschiedliche vorschläge zum teil
auch wenig abgestimmte wie wir heute
gesehen haben horst seehofer hatte er
vorgeschlagen eine journalistin
anzuzeigen nach einem gespräch mit der
bundeskanzlerin hat er sich das wohl
doch noch einmal überlegt und sagt jetzt
lediglich wird dies weiter prüfen
also da gibt es noch einiges an debatte
den parteien wird hier so scheint es
eine debatte auf gezwungen die sie zwar
haben kommen sehen
auf die sie sich aber noch nicht richtig
vorbereitet haben vielen dank für ihre
einschätzung schon unter ben ali und eva
schiller schauen wir auf die zahlen der
korona pandemie da liegt der sogenannte
erwert die re produktionszahl mit 2,88
deutlich über der kritischen marke von 1
das robert koch institut erklärt dies
unter anderem mit dem hotspot beim
schlachtbetrieb tennis weil die korona
fallzahlen in deutschland aktuell sehr
niedrig sind beeinflussen regionale
ausbrüche der wert relativ stark
entsprechend steigt auch die zahl der
neuinfektionen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 540 menschen neu mit dem virus
angesteckt
nach den corona fällen in der
fleischfabrik turniers werden weitere
einschränkungen für die bevölkerung im
kreis gütersloh erwogen die zahl der
infizierten ist auf mehr als 1500 an
gestiegen arbeitsminister heil will nun
den fleischkonzern für die folgen zur
kasse bitten turniers wird vorgeworfen
die mitarbeiter nicht ausreichend vor
ansteckung geschützt zu haben so was
minden
es ist ein beschämendes bild 600
leiharbeiter der firma tönnies sitzen in
werl buchstäblich hinter gittern
manz hohe bauzäune durch die sie bei
landwirten ohne quarantäne pflicht
bestellungen aufgeben
dann warten und schließlich die tüten in
empfang nehmen sozialamtsleiterin
barbara männer stört vor allem der
eindruck die arbeiter seien an
irgendetwas schuld ich finde diese täter
frage ist eine unsägliche geschichte
niemand ist hier täter hier gibt es nur
opfer das muss man ganz klar sagen wer
das ist ein virus und gegen das kann man
sich nicht schützen
bei den eigentlich verantwortlichen im
15 kilometer entfernten räder steht der
betrieb jetzt wirklich still
selbst die werbung haben sie angehalten
nur äußern wollen sie sich auch heute
nicht bei einer pressekonferenz heute
abend steht dann plötzlich wieder der
totale lockdown für den kreis gütersloh
im raum
aber ja im vergleich zu gestern eine
etwas andere lage haben dadurch dass wir
in den mobilen teams ja nochmal jetzt
wir wissen es noch nicht ganz genau aber
doch doch noch einige positive fälle
gefunden haben wie man gespannt was noch
so passiert ich halte alles für möglich
die landesregierung berät zur stunde
darüber
weiteres thema hier inwieweit die firma
tönnies für die kosten dieses krone
ausbruchs verantwortlich gemacht werden
kann
und ich selber habe ja mit freude
festgestellt dass es bereit ist die
kosten für die testungen zu übernehmen
und ich kann mir auch durchaus
vorstellen dass hoeneß sich diese frage
aufstellt und die quarantäne einen
totalen lockdown im kreis gütersloh
verhindern kann entscheidet sich
womöglich schon heute abend billig
billiger am billigsten
der turnier skandal hat die debatte über
faire preise für lebensmittel wieder
angesagt zumal auch in deutschland
supermärkten gerade eine neue
rabattschlacht beginnt auslöser die
senkung der mehrwertsteuer enthalten im
corona konjunkturpaket der
bundesregierung
stichtag ist da zwar eigentlich der
erste juli doch eine der größten
discounter senkt die preise bereits
jetzt deutlich aber
berichtet lidl presst vorn hat vor allen
anderen konkurrenten heute bereits die
mehrwertsteuer gesenkt acht tage vor der
offiziellen steuersenkung die meisten
kunden wie hier in bonn freuen sich man
kann viel mehr kaufen
das merkt man gern verträge und bringt
für mich aber auch gar nichts
die mehrwertsteuer zu senken eine
politische idee trotzdem warnen die
verantwortlichen vor rabattschlachten
niedriger die preise sind und je weniger
die preise den wert des lebensmittels
tatsächlich widerspiegeln desto größere
probleme hat man mit arbeitsbedingungen
in betrieben und matthias
schutzstandards experten gehen von
weiter sinkenden lebensmittelpreisen aus
auch aldi wirbt heute mit rabatten um
kunden für die discounter geht es darum
verbraucher zurückzugewinnen
die der korona krise doch lieber bei den
großen vollsortimentern eingekauft haben
lidl geht davon aus dass die wirtschaft
in eine rezession geht das haben die
internen auch schon bei management
meetings verkündet und deswegen stellen
die sich jetzt darauf ein dass die
kunden preissensitiver werden und ihr
einkaufsverhalten anpassen und noch mehr
als bisher darauf achten dass nur
wirklich der letzte cent gespart werden
kann
deutschland ist die mutter der
discounter die kunden hier sind wie in
keinem anderen eu land dazu erzogen
extrem auf preise zu achten vom liebling
der finanzmärkte zum ungebremsten
absturz an der börse
beim zahlungsdienstleister wirecard
reichten dafür wenige tage die
finanzaufsicht bafin spricht heute von
einem totalen desaster und räumt
selbstkritisch eigenes versagen ein
luftbuchungen in milliarden-höhe blieben
viel zu lange unbemerkt selbst eine wild
card insolvenz wird nun nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen alexander pohl eine
meldung die es in sich hat die 1,9
milliarden euro
die auf konten asiatischer banken liegen
sollten existieren höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht zweifel an den geschäftspartnern
hat es seit langem gegeben warum
fragen experten hat niemand etwas
unternommen das war ja selbst nicht die
aufklärung betrieben hat obwohl sie
wussten dass etwas im argen sein muss
ist schon erstaunlich aber es ist noch
erstaunlicher dass auch der aufsichtsrat
und dass selbst die bafin nicht drauf
gekommen sind seit anfang 2009 10
berichtet die financial times immer
wieder über mitarbeiter in asien
die scheingeschäfte getätigt bilanzen
gefälscht und gelder veruntreut haben
sollen
vor ein paar wochen dann äußern
wirtschaftsprüfer zweifel an der
existenz der milliardenschweren
treuhandkonten niemand scheint hellhörig
zu werden
der chef der obersten
finanzaufsichtsbehörde spricht heute von
einem kompletten desaster von einer
schande für den finanzplatz deutschland
wir sind nicht effektiv genug gewesen
einen solchen fall zu verhindern
ich nehme die öffentliche kritik voll
und ganz an der tiefe fall eines
börsenstar es dabei gilt die technologie
mit der wirecard bargeldlose zahlungen
weltweit abwickelt nach wie vor als
zukunftsfähig sagen fachleute
in deutschland haben wir nicht sehr
viele zukunftsträchtige unternehmen im
high tech sektor und da ist sehr wichtig
dass man jetzt ganz nüchtern betrachtet
das operative geschäft irgendwo rettet
in den nächsten tagen entscheidet sich
ob die banken die bestehenden kredite
für wirecard weiter gewähren werden
deutschlands höchstes gericht hat seit
heute einen neuen chef
präsident des bundesverfassungsgerichts
ist nun stephan harbarth lange jahre
abgeordnete der cdu im bundestag
er löst andreas voßkuhle ab der von
bundespräsident steinmeier verabschiedet
wurde
christoph schneider für andreas voßkuhle
ist es ein schlusspunkt nach
zwölfjähriger amtszeit am
bundesverfassungsgericht davon zehn
jahre als präsident eine verabschiedung
mit dem großkreuz des verdienstordens
der bundesrepublik
sie haben das bundesverfassungsgericht
exzellent nach außen vertreten der
präsident ist das gesicht des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes und ihr
gesicht machte die institution im staat
sichtbar neues gesicht dieser
institution ist stephan harbarth seit
zwei jahren richter am
bundesverfassungsgericht bisheriger
vizepräsident für ihn steht der schutz
der demokratie an oberster stelle sagte
im zdf wir leben doch global betrachtet
in einer zeit in der autoritäre
führungsmodelle sich wieder eines
erhöhten zulaufs erfreut und davon ist
die ganze welt erfasst und auch wir in
deutschland merken wir leben in gewisser
weise in einer schwankenden zeit als
abgeordneter saß stephan harbarth bis zu
seiner wahl 2018 für die cdu im
bundestag
und da war rechtsanwalt in einer großen
wirtschaftskanzlei was auch für kritik
sorgte herberts amtszeit geht bis 2030
zeit genug manche kritiker zu überzeugen
und wenn sie den neuen
verfassungsgerichtspräsidenten haar bart
und das was ihn bewegt kennenlernen
wollen dann können sie das gleich im
anschluss an diese nachrichten in der
sendung was nun herr herbert die usa und
russland verhandeln über einen neuen
vertrag zur atomaren abrüstung
hochrangige vertreter beider länder
beraten in wien über eine fortsetzung
des bisherigen new start abkommens das
im nächsten jahr ausläuft
es sieht vor die nuklear waffen der usa
und russlands auf je 800 trägersysteme
und 1550 atomsprengköpfe zu verringern
russland drängt auf eine verlängerung
washington dagegen fordert die atommacht
china in das abkommen mit einzubeziehen
bei der präsidentenwahl in serbien hat
die regierende sogenannte
fortschrittspartei von präsident hu jia
klar gewonnen nach angaben der
wahlbehörden kamen sie auf etwa 61
prozent der stimmen
die grössten oppositionsparteien hatten
die wahl boykottiert
sie werfen bout cic einen zunehmend
autoritären regierungsstil vor und
sprachen von unfairen bedingungen seine
rechtsnationale partei regiert seit
bereits seit 2012 und jetzt die frage
wie war der urlaub genauer gesagt wie
war es auf mallorca heute vor einer
woche hatten die balearen wieder
aufgemacht für tausende deutsche -test
touristen ein experiment ein probelauf
für flughäfen hotels und gäste wie also
funktioniert der urlaub mit anti corona
maske abstand und desinfektionsmittel
eine erste bilanz zieht thomas walde all
inclusive auf mallorca dass es für
marcel reif holz und daniel vogt eine
woche lang auch schutzmaßnahmen gegen
korona sicher haben wir uns
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich sicherer als
in deutschland gefüllt
man konnte beobachten dass die kräfte
gerade vom hotel wirklich sehr aktiv
waren
deutschland galt wegen geringer corona
zahlen hier als sicheres herkunftsland
touristen aus anderen ländern durften
zunächst nicht einreisen spanien wollte
einen neustart mit wenig risiko
unser fazit ist dass es sehr gut
gelaufen ist wir sind sehr glücklich es
hat das geboten was wir zeigen wollten
nämlich dass für sicherheitsmaßnahmen
eingeführt haben neue corona fälle durch
touristen sind bisher nicht bekannt
geworden für einheimische ist dennoch
nicht alles wie zuvor
das virus ist noch da und wenn wir nicht
vorsichtig sind gibt das einem neuen
ausbruch jetzt hat spanien seine grenzen
für andere europäer geöffnet und
reisholz und vogt nahmen heute morgen
etwas in ihrem gepäck mit die hoffnung
einer region dass ihr beispiel zeigen
möge das urlaub trotz corona möglich ist
und nun zu den ort und zur
fußball-bundesliga bei uns im fernsehen
und da können sich die fans des
aktuellen sportstudios und der
sportschau freuen
die bundesliga zusammenfassung am
samstag die gibt es auch in den nächsten
jahren bei ard und zdf in gewohnter form
neu bei uns spielberichte im internet
auf zdf.de die fußball-bundesliga
emotion tour auf dem rasen und am
spielfeldrand auf den rängen mit und
ohne fans und die bundesliga im
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen und
damit erst einmal einen schönen guten
abend fußball der zuschauer liebstes
kind auch ab 2021 frei empfangbar im zdf
wir freuen uns mit dem aktuellen
sportstudio eine wichtige tradition
fortführen zu können und die clip rechte
fürs internet sind eine bedeutsame
investition für die zukunft
und die liegt auch im internet die
finanzielle zukunft der vereine ist
durch den abschluss bis 2025 gesichert
trotz leichten einnahmerückgang wir
sprechen immerhin noch über ein
investment von 4,4 milliarden euro das
jetzt getätigt wird bis 2025 da kann man
dann schon ganz ordentlichen fußball von
organisiert bleibt zu hoffen dass das
bis 2021 wieder vor vollen rängen
stattfindet dicht gedrängte zuschauer
sorglos feiernde tennisprofis die
umstrittene adria tour organisiert vom
weltranglisten ersten novak djokovic
die hat folgen die spieler grigor
dimitrov und bonner college sind positiv
auf kona getestet worden
bilder die bei vielen unverständnis
hervorrufen organisator novak djokovic
und tennisprofis wie alexander zverev
tummeln sich in belgrad unter
zahlreichen zuschauern und das hand zu
sehen wir den ganzen zuschauen wenn die
ganzen leute ich habe so viele leute
glaube ich schon seit ein paar monaten
nicht mehr gesehen sollte wahrscheinlich
die infizierten der bulgaren grigor
dimitrov von borna college aus kroatien
spielten am samstag in zadar gegen
einander beide zeigen bisher keine
symptome und entschuldigten sich mit
posts für mögliche folgen dimitrov
empfahl allen die mit ihm in kontakt
gewesen sein sich testen zu lassen
party szenen rund um djokovic kreatur
haben zusätzlich für empörung gesorgt
während das finale in saada abgesagt
wurde bleibt offen ob die umstrittene
tennis tour anfang juli in sarajevo
weitergehen könnte in dieser woche wird
es von tag zu tag wärmer und sommerliche
wann es wie heiß genau wird sagt uns
gleich katja honnefer das war es von uns
danke für ihr interesse
christian sievers freut sich um drei
viertel 10 auf see und wir sind morgen
hier wieder zur stelle punkt 19 uhr
jetzt geht es weiter mit was nun noch
einen entspannten abend und machen sie
es gut
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
wird eine sommerwoche die steht unter
dem zeichen von hochhuths auch wenn
heute noch einige regenwolken über uns
hinweg gezogen sind
es war meist nur ganz kleine regenwolken
vielleicht in fritzlar hat es mal
geregnet oder auch an den alpen und
genau am alpenrand erwarten wir jetzt
auch in der nacht einige letzte
regentropfen soll server die nacht klar
und so sinken die temperaturen auf 13
grad auf rügen auch am main wird zu kühl
genauso wie an der donau noch kälter
wird es im nordhessischen bergland mit
sieben grad und morgen strahlt dann
wieder die sonne von tagesbeginn anlass
sind jetzt zur zeit etwa 17
sonnenstunden und nur hier zwischen dem
spreewald und dem erzgebirge und
zwischen den bayerischen wald und im
allgäu sind die wolken mal etwas dichter
haben das hat dann sofort konsequenzen
für die temperaturen die dort nämlich
nur auf 21 bis 24 grad klettern
ähnlich wie nordöstlich der elbe und an
der nordsee im westen und südwesten
gegen geht's auf 25 bis 28 grad drauf
und das steigern wäre in dieser woche
sogar am samstag erwarten uns dann
deutschlandweit temperaturen zwischen 26
grad an der ostsee und 33 grad an der
elbe und dazu gibt es nur selten mal ein
paar kleine wärmegewitter schönen abend
noch